des soupçons d'ingérences qui semblent
se confirmer il y a quelques mois juste
un Trudeau assuré pourtant que les
élections fédérales n'avaient pas été
compromises par Pékin l'intégrité de nos
élections n'ont pas été compromis mais
dans cet article du globet de merde on
apprend que le régime chinois a employé
une stratégie sophistiquée pour
influencer le résultat des élections de
2021 l'objectif de Pékin faire élire un
gouvernement libéral minoritaire et se
débarrasser des candidats critiques à
l'endroit de la Chine notamment en
menant des campagnes de désinformation
contre des conservateurs
fermer les yeux parce que les rapports
secrets qu'il recevaient l'avantageait
les Québécois veulent savoir le
gouvernement va-t-il enfin prendre enfin
prendre cette menace au sérieux ils font
réagir le chef conservateur
était au courant de cette ingérence et
il a accepté parce que l'ingérance était
dans sa faveur la sécurité Justin
Trudeau lui persiste et signe son
gouvernement prend la menace au sérieux
et Pékin n'a pas influencé le résultat
des élections les résultats des
élections en 2019 en 2021
c'est les résultats qu'on choisit
les électeurs canadiens point à la ligne
des révélations troublantes selon cette
expert qui démontre le caractère
insidieux de l'ingérence chinoise
on ignore toujours ce que le premier
ministre savait exactement des efforts
déployés par Pékin lors des dernières
élections et tant que cette question
restera à sans réponse le dossier de
l'ingérence étrangère restera une épine
au pied du gouvernement Trudeau ici à
semaine midi Radio-Canada Toronto